[Musik]
so leute herzlich willkommen zur
nächsten folge war
ich nehme im anschluss auf die letzte
auf weil ich hoffe dass ich vorne wieder
den abgang findet bei der letzten folge
hatte okay die anderen wären direkt
gekickt und ja irgendwie ich bin jetzt
halt wieder drei folgen im voraus das
heißt keiner weiß wahrscheinlich wo ich
bin
es sei denn die wissen wie lebensmittel
ich bin und haben meiner folge letztens
gesehen dass ich mich tatsächlich
einfach im spore unterbau so wo es jetzt
nochmal der abgang gewesen wie man sieht
sie nicht so genau
verdammt ich hatte gehofft dass man es
noch dass man dennoch findet und ich bin
wieder auch mit dabei ist auch mit dabei
gleichzeitig ist jetzt sauer ich wollte
schon wieder die magische mit einem
staat holen
du kannst es nicht getan
wo war das denn jetzt ich hatte doch
lieb mich hier einfach irgendwo unter
gebaut
achso übrigens die change motto ich hab
gerade schon die ganze zeit den fehler
gemacht die change von heute ist nicht
zu fliegen
also auch wenn einer auf den server
kommt da habe ich einfach nichts liegen
weil ich sonst gegen die regeln verstoße
und wieder zurück runter in die kleine
höhle die wir gefunden haben
ich habe jetzt mittlerweile immerhin mal
eine kleine perle die mich retten kann
oder wird oder so ich glaube wer dann
noch du also bei mir ist es halt so ich
sitze hier gerade und hat minecraft
offen und denkt man die gans oder steht
auf dem server sind ist gerade jemand
und ich würde auch gerne sein aber in
wirklichkeit
hast du etwa immer noch die wahl wie
würdest du sie für 500.000 likes auf
seinem neuesten video veröffentlichen
ich glaube wenn mich jeder wenn ich wenn
nicht okay okay okay da wird er
hellhörig wenn es um sex geht
wenn ihr diesen video von max ich würde
mal sagen
20.000 daumen hoch gibt ja dann gebe ich
euch die vip so kann es jedoch nicht
doch eher einen mit allen daten drauf du
wirst von allen gewünscht den korvetten
mal ins wasser drin sind
ich hab die ip war schon mal kurz
öffentlich oder sie wurde auf jeden fall
gewechselt ja das habe ich auch gehört
wie ich mich wundert ja sehr dass direkt
unter dem spawn einfach so ein
gigantisches höhlensystem ist 110 jahre
alt gewesen wenn man sich direkt bei mir
jetzt keinen sinn ergeben wenn man sich
direkt über baute der geht natürlich
nicht so nicht so einfach da und jetzt
nehmen wir alles mal wieder mit ich bin
eigentlich echt nicht mehr so ich bin ja
leute tester darüber wird mal reden so
warum soll ich darüber rede ich kann
mich schon fragen ob man die magischen
miesmuschel der ball komm ich für intro
sequenz warum sollte ich darüber reden
magischen miesmuschel warum wollte mag
sein ich darüber reden tut mir leid was
anderes wie viel grad draußen in köln
grad eben wahrscheinlich eine magische
ja es war es jemals wirklich gut
lediglich die folgen wo wir verfolgen
würden zufolge drei bis fünf oder so
oder 4 und 5 fand ich richtig spannend
ich auch als gerade wird wieder übels
lächerlich
ja das stimmt wir haben anfang haben wir
ein bisschen faxen macht aber ich meine
leute was soll ich denn groß machen wenn
ich hier ganz alleine bin wenn ich
irgendwelche faxe nirgends ganze
spannend zu gestalten oder zumindest
unterhaltsam
also ich gebe ich zu die folgen jetzt
gerade nicht spannend aber immer noch
besser als wenn ich hier einfach
langweilig rumlaufe und probiere
irgendwie durch strippen einen diamanten
zu finden challenge an dich mach doch
mal die managerin challenge league die
ganze zeit im kopf als fan tut mir leid
hey was ich jetzt brauchte bestrafung
ich sage jetzt eine zahl zwischen 1 und
9 und dieses alter musste jetzt unten in
der liste wegschmeißen
walter ich weiß nicht ob ich das machen
will
magst du sortiert jetzt nicht ein
inventar um nein mach ich mich okay sagt
er mache halt wirklich nichts mache ich
echt nicht versprichst du kannst dir
anschauen
das erste item ein schwert wird ein
zweites ja nciht ein schwert immer wenn
du jetzt musste das mache ich nie ist es
voll schwierig ich kann mich packt
erstmal die ender perle aus maine aus
der aus der liste weil die will ich echt
nicht verlieren
[Musik]
ich will doch nur dass man diesen teil
auch locker genug andere leute auf dem
server gewesen die letzten male mit mir
die wären sie ansporn gewesen mich
einfach hätten töten können was das für
den satzbau aber er ist glaube ich
trotzdem richtig gewesen
der war einfach komplett richtig ist
einfach deutsche sprache ist ziemlich
verrückt während sie ansporn gewesen
hätten sie mich töten können so viele
starts unnötig geworden wörter ok komm
schon
mann ich will doch einfach nur noch
diamanten also übrigens luca du bist ja
gleich weg na ja also ich bleibe noch
genau fünf minuten
sehr gut habe ich alle fünf minuten
alleine ist ja nicht so wild bei red hat
man dort oft gesagt den rest bleibe ich
auch noch her sonst ist das ein blöder
karte in der folge das ist cool das ist
lieb von dir geht man als lukas neuesten
video und lasst ihn leichter in einigen
kommentaren like sehe ich ja nicht
einfach 1 kommentar damit ich sehe dass
die leute von max kommt schreibt gruß
von max in einem wort unter lukas
neuestes video das ganz wichtig ok ich
sprinte ich schon die frohe kunde
geteilt was ab dem 15 januar passiert
das datum noch nicht gesagt aber ich
kann ja jetzt sagen ich werde am 15
januar nach köln ziehen
was bedeutet es bedeutet doch was mit
wasser
naja was bedeutet es dass ich in das ich
dann dort mit würden mit irgendeinem
mehr videos kommen alston wir zumindest
sein dass wir sehr viel mehr zusammen
hochladen derzeit ist es halt so immer
wenn maximal in köln ist oder der
zwischenzeit nicht mal ein mal im jahr
bei max zu hause bin wird so sein dass
ist es halt so dass wir dann immer so
drei vier videos aufnehmen dann haben
wir erst mal so videos und wir denken
sogar diesem fall gut geworden die
kommen auch immer mehr gut an
und wenn max ist ab dem 15 januar in
köln bonn was hat auch schon in vier
wochen ist ehrlich gesagt so amon gehalt
in unmittelbarer nähe zueinander und
werden uns dann voll auf treffen und zu
videos zusammen aufnehmen und so das
ding dann hat er sich richtig im auge
gedrückt sage ich mal
das wird richtig stark also ich glaube
die die zeit wieder richtig spaß machen
auf youtube ja ich freue mich auch schon
ja aber jetzt will ich das habe ich
schon mal gesagt die hand
also ich meine ich kann mich enttäuschen
aber ich meine dass zwölf die perfekte
die höhe
ich hab es nicht dass man sie wegwerfen
auf der 400 schaufel es ist so schwierig
nicht so sie mieten das weißt du gar
nicht vorstellen wie fast immer wenn ich
laufe ja ja das macht man einfach aus
reflex weil man sonst immer irgendwo
runterstürzen immer wenn ich um die
kurve laufe einfach ich gehe also
gebückt ja genau
auch nicht dass jetzt hacke ist kaputt
ich denke mir die ganze zeit dass ich
die shift taste nicht drücken darf aber
das ist ja falsch weil es das darf ich
hab's nicht wegwerfen deine schuhe meine
stoffen an luca du hast gesagt eine zahl
von 1 bis 9
okay außer hot bahn dann sage ich einst
schon wieder man schwer mein stein
schwert jetzt wenn ich jetzt eine
angreift bin ich total das weißt du
eigentlich dass die challenge ich denke
auch die asse techniken dabei die tasten
direkt nebeneinander sind und dass ihr
schiff klicken darf wenn ich sachen aus
dem ofen mode ist es so verdammt
schwierig du machst nicht fertig
klarschrift darfst du drückt mir die
sachen aus dem ofen holz ja aber ich
meine ich floh ihre so in meinem kopf
die taste sage ich mal dhabi teil selbst
schuld habe ich natürlich dann sprinten
david geffen ein bisschen kohle holen da
vorne und ich habe gesagt verdammt noch
mal was greift nicht an
ich habe kein schwert mehr eine axt utes
august jetzt die einst wegschmeißen weil
sich direkt die 1 ist gerade cool
diesmal abgebaut hat machen
[Musik]
origin richie rich und das kind schwer
wo ist mein ofen nein ich bin so
schlecht bitte finde ich den ofen wieder
darum ist die witch dass man offen und
erst mal ein schwert und ich habe aus
versehen die kohle wieder auf gruppen
nee das war neulich ab word up oder mich
ganz sicher
ich nehme jetzt alles mir egal ob dieser
effekt jetzt erst mal auf die schnauze
von mir ja ich glaube die irgendwie
porschen
okay man die nur leere flaschen
die brauche ich nicht vielen dank
so erfolgt was sagst du fand ganz
sammeln
ich kannte auch so lustig 1 kommentar
bei mir war so du hast mich ja gefragt
ich kann aber das nicken und springen
oder und beschreibt seine in meinem
kommentar luca doppelpunkt ich kann aber
das nicken und springen gleichzeitig
oder fragezeichen von crafter wünscht
sich macht man kraftwerk einem effekt
wäre aus weil schon ziemlich lustig
so also etwa wie soll ich gar nicht so
viel kommentierte voll natürlich nicht
sagen wo ich an deiner stelle ehrlich
nicht sagen ja es ist aber auch langsam
langweilig man ich hab jetzt lustig mal
die us zu finden oder ich lasse das
ganze einfach bekämpft mit jemanden mit
dem schlechten zeug was ich jetzt habe
also macht einfach gerade irgendwie
nicht so lust zu spielen ich fand es
eigentlich schon ganz nice wie die
ersten folgen bei uns gelaufen sind
ich fand es eigentlich auch cool also
ich meine es war halt so immer mit spaß
mit drin aber andererseits war es bei
mir halt auch so dass das wir dann halt
verfolgt wurden wieder keine ahnung ja
es war so eine gute mischung
schade ist vorbei ist
ich habe überall mich schon umgebaut ein
bisschen zeug werfen weil wir ich hab
grad bei facebook auf sein video
geklickt steht so die krasseste
taschenlampe sie es für das militär
selbst verboten aber man kann sich jetzt
bestellt ich lasse mich immer leiten von
werbeanzeigen und ich habe hier langsam
echt alles umgegraben
alles alles ich will alles alles alles
alles alles alles alles alles alles
alles verlust alles alles alles alles
alles alles alles alles auch nein nicht
zugehört so riediger service nicht
leiten
ich konnte ja nicht wissen dass nicht
alles willst du wirst alles holen was
willst du dann alles nur einmal nein
wenn luca bei merck war es durch den 35
man alles wenn deine mutter 5 durch die
märkte uns wird es mir egal wenn ich
dann heute leiden will macht einfach
deine mutter hat dein vater [ __ ]
stimmt dich ich hoffe mal leute werden
wir wahrscheinlich tausend mal schreiben
dass ich noch gesiegt habe in der
zwischenzeit aber bewusst habe ich das
auf jeden fall nicht getan
dabei vorgeschrieben sogar bei der jahre
nicht geschafft ihr vorausgesagt und von
oft nicht ja aber da denkt man in dem
moment einfach nicht daran einfach an
spannung versorgen
also das war halt wirklich krasse wir
machen diese mega damit challenge und
haben einfach gleichzeitig den tod im
nacken
also leute ich weiß nicht also ich bin
unzufrieden muss ich sagen
ihr werde es wahrscheinlich auch sein
aber irgendwie passiert jetzt hier in
den folgen nicht so was sollte ich hatte
eigentlich gehofft dass ein paar diaz
finde oder dass zumindest einer der
herrscher und bisschen action ist aber
wie es halt nicht
mal sehen was hier in den nächsten
folgen mache ein bisschen schade
ich hoffe es hat euch trotzdem gefallen
könnt ihr kommentare schreiben für neue
coole channel wenn ihr hunderttausend
gleich auf dieses video schafft dann
bringe ich mich selbst und warum